[Music]
hello I'm Dan wattenberg there is a
great deal of sex and violence on
television in the movies and in our
popular music does this lead to
unacceptable behavior is this corseting
our lives or our sex and violence age
old staples of art and literature in any
event what tools are available in a free
society to change popular culture
joining us to sort through the conflict
and the consensus are Camille Pollock
professor of humanities at the
University of the Arts in Philadelphia
and author of the recently published
vamps and tramps Robert Bork senior
fellow at the American Enterprise
Institute and author of the forthcoming
book slouching toward Gomorrah modern
liberalism and American decline and John
Leo columnist for US News and World
Report and author of two steps ahead of
the thought police the topic before this
house does Hollywood hurt America this
week on think-tank
[Music]
it is one of America's great ironies we
love to watch television to go to the
movies and to listen to popular music
but when we do many of us strongly
object to what we see or hear and we are
especially concerned about what our
children see in here recently Senate
Majority Leader and Republican
presidential contender Bob Dole attacked
Hollywood our music movies television
and advertising regularly pushed the
limits of decency and they bombard our
children with destructive message of
casual violence and even more casual sex
and I concluded that we must hold
Hollywood and the entire entertainment
industry accountable for putting profit
ahead of common decency dole criticized
movies like Natural Born Killers
[Music]
wait
[Music]
and true romantic I don't kill anybody
since 1984 dull and others have singled
out the Time Warner corporation for
particular criticism I'm C Delores
Tucker chair of the national political
Congress of black women I'm Bill Bennett
co-director of empower America I'm a
Liberal Democrat and I'm a conservative
Republican Time Warner's music division
promotes music that celebrates the rape
torture and murder of women the lyrics
are vulgar offensive and do terrible
harm to our children isn't anybody at
Time Warner embarrassed by these lyrics
Time Warner's response has been quite
cautious quote it is certainly not an
easy matter to decide who the ultimate
arbiter of creative content should be we
prefer to err on the side of freedom of
expression end quotes
President Clinton had spoken out even
earlier people in the entertainment
industry in this country we applaud your
creativity in your worldwide success and
we support your freedom of expression
but you do have a responsibility to
assess the impact of your work and to
understand the damage that comes from
the incessant repetitive mindless
violence and irresponsible conduct that
permeates our media
okay
panel lady and gentlemen President
Clinton and the senator Dole think that
sex and violence in the movies can cause
bad behavior judge Bob Bork do you think
that there is a relationship between
what we see on our television screens
and here in popular music and actual
behavior if there isn't the advertisers
are wasting billions of dollars a year
Michael Medved cites over 3,000 studies
that show that a diet of constant
violence of entertainment leads to
aggressive antisocial behavior as toward
sex I think the lady who worked with
single mothers put it best they said how
can we stop the legitimacy she said
shoot Madonna now that may be a little
extreme
but you see her point Camille paulien
does depraved or decadent popular
culture cause depraved or a decadent
behavior well it's a great fan of
Madonna I feel I have to say that I am
more skeptical than judge Bork of those
thousands of studies which I believe
only show an anecdotal and incidental
kind of relationship between what is
seen on screen and what is done in the
street I think in fact that it that
violent fictions may may provide a kind
of cathartic release for certain eternal
human energies by this standard we would
have to look very closely at Hamlet
let's say or which it which has multiple
corpses on the stage at the end this was
in fact the argument of the Puritans
used to close the theatres in
Shakespeare's time or we'd have to look
at Edith's wrecks all of Greek drama it
seems to me is full of barbarities okay
John Leigh oh I think it obviously does
have an effect I mean the popular
culture is the air that our kids breathe
and if you call women hoes and [ __ ]
and a thousand songs you shouldn't be
surprised if young males start to treat
them that way how do you account for the
fact I mean Camille alluded to it that
in earlier times I mean we had cartoons
and westerns and private-eye movies and
monster movies and cop shows as well as
terrible violence in Shakespeare and
Sophocles and and terrible's terribly
interesting amusing
sexuality and Aristophanes and so on and
so forth so why do you claim that now is
different either either ago let me jump
in I think that Camille is right that
there's a cathartic aspect to it but
that works best in a stable culture with
social controls when you have a culture
that seems to be melting down as ours
does you're going to find the next
generation taking its messages of quick
solutions through violence from the
screen it's not just that there's some
violence and Hamlet it's that that our
children are watching thousands of
murders and Bruce Willis is upping the
body count in every die hard I think
that gets through to kids particularly
young males that that's the way to solve
things and it's an OK solution kids
watch about 20 hours of television a
week and the counts for violence and
murder is very high I forget exactly
what it is because I see 9 murders an
evening they don't see Shakespeare that
many times we ranged in Shakespeare's
time saw Shakespeare that many times or
Sophocles inside I don't think anybody
saw Shakespeare 20 hours a week but be
that as it may also the violence was
presented in the different context there
it had a plot to it there was a reason
for it the violence now they always
refer to it as senseless violence it is
it's just for the pleasure of seeing
bodies fly apart I think there's been a
terrible decline in aesthetic standards
in Hollywood but I feel this is due to a
transition from the great Hollywood
studio era to the America the 1950s when
television has now kept mass audiences
at home so over the last thirty years I
feel there has been an evolution in the
kind of movies being made the only
people who really go out to movies now
are young people people unday to like
this kinds of cartoony mutilation of
bodies and so on there's no doubt that
just in the period since I was in
college this is a great era of
incredible classy philosophical foreign
films art films that are completely gone
now I do I am concerned as a professor
about the condition of America I am a
great lover of popular culture but we
cannot have the young raised only on a
diet of popular culture this is why I am
for also the Canon of great writers in
order to
balance out as opposed to censorship I
say build up the high art and the study
of great thinkers this is a people other
than teenagers including me do watch
movies I happen to think movies I mean
the ones I watch are pretty wonderful we
have a it is a great American art form
it is being watched by more people these
days plus the international market this
is what is showing Americas face for
good or for ill I think mostly for good
I think many of those messages many of
those movies have a message of American
individualism and upward mobility and so
why are we why are we beating up on the
fact that some of it is rotten well I'll
give you an example I'll use a
Republican perpetrator essence Bob Dole
did I like the Terminator movies but in
the in Terminator 2 Schwarzenegger comes
down naked from the future and his first
act is to walk into a pool room and beat
the living hell out of these guys who
have jackets and motorcycles that he
wants well first of all this is a
typical urban crime but secondly it's
also seen through his eyes you walk in
you see it through his eyes and you were
invited to enjoy the decimation of these
characters who have done nothing it's
it's a pro violence message in a way
that you don't you didn't used to get in
American movies you are given the taste
and feel of violence and it's made very
inviting and you're justified you're
here to stop world war 3 so it's ok ok I
don't feel there's a direct relationship
between such movies and such scenes and
the actual violence in the streets for
me
there are sociological factors for for
the violence in the streets and that is
the utter breakdown of of community life
in the inner city because of the flight
of the of the black middle-class to get
to the suburbs and the end the absence
now of manufacturing jobs there are a
lot of unemployed black youth I point of
fact can remember stories that my my
relatives told of the violence of
italian-american youth was 60 years ago
let's say we really should really
examine the you know the level of of
juvenile delinquency among among ethnics
other than blacks from the early part of
the set of the century I'm not so sure
you know they have they have better
weapons than they did then they they
used to settle problems with knives and
fists and now unfortunately with
haven't you written Camille that you
think pornography is good stuff yes I am
radically Pro porn I know that that is
an extreme position because I feel that
pornography shows the truth about
sexuality the truth about our animal
nature's at the same time I feel that it
is appropriate and to ask the
pornography not be displayed in public
spaces that it should be available for
private consumption that that no one
hasn't has the right to intrude into
public spaces and to and it is a movie
theater a public space no not in the
sense that a public square or let's say
even a newsstand would be in other words
I want the pornography available at the
newsstand
I don't feel anyone has the right to
display the pornography for for
Christian people who are wondering the
problem is the people who enjoy the
pornography change they change
themselves and they change themselves
for the worst on internet right now I've
learned that you can get all sex stories
and there you can read about the
castration of a seven year old boy and
then is being shot about the gang rape
of a six year old girl
you can get stories telling you when to
lurk outside of girls school how the
bundle into the van whether to tell her
in advance after you're finished whether
she's going to be murdered that stuff is
on internet now now wait old George
Gilder is digital films from all over
the world and you have just repeated it
on public television
my point that that that the effort the
the coalition between the religious
right and the feminist anti-porn wing
has failed that they thought they had
they had finally cornered the market and
limited it in the realm of pornographic
films and videos but look the moment
there's a new medium of communication
the the the what can I say the perverse
human soul bubbles up everywhere and so
to me the presence of these of these or
horrific stories on the internet simply
proves my point that it may be the human
imagination that we cannot fully police
well we used to have restraints of
various kind it's not only law but
religion and morality that kept these
things in the corner at best now it's
out in the open and it may be the
technology as such
that would be impossible to control it
all right well let's go John I was going
to say that I agree with Camille that
that various ethnic groups committed
horrific violence the Irish were very
good at it and they into the last
century but it usually came under
control because of the churches and the
institutions which are now in collapse
so I think the attention to the public
culture now is partly to acknowledge
that the family and the churches can't
can't stop this if the public culture is
the preacher now so whatever is put into
the pot of the public culture is likely
to have direct effects and it didn't
have before all right let us stipulate
that I you have at least one skeptic
here me but let us stipulate that that
that that bad culture drives bad
behavior what are you going to do about
it you you alluded fondly to censorship
if only well yes I think it's inevitable
that was we're gonna try censorship at
some stage I didn't used to think so I
thought that this public culture was
beyond agreement on any form of
censorship but when you get the kind of
stuff that's now on internet the kind of
stuff I described and when that appears
in digital films you can watch on your
home computer I think we're in a very
dangerous situation as we begin to
appeal to perverts who could be
triggered into action and I think we're
gonna have to try censorship whether we
can do it or not I don't know you would
like to see it succeed oh yes I don't
want that kind of stuff floating around
in the society any I mean not even on
display that the public news then the
way Camille was saying it's not out in
front of you but you can say I want a
copy of hustler and get it I'm worried
about the fellow who wants to get
stories about young children being raped
and murdered that is not a normal mind
and I don't want to trigger that all
right what about playboy penthouse
getting down to hustler what about those
magazines well I haven't seen got too
embarrassed in the barber shop pick one
up so I haven't received one for a long
part of your research you could purchase
one yeah that's right
no I have seen occasional and some of
them I think deserve censorship John I
think the real part of the First
Amendment
no I'm not for such my my solution
however dreamy is a change in
consciousness I think cultures do change
sexual attitudes change abruptly from
generation to generation as they have
through English history quite regularly
and I think we can change your
consciousness in America
well my analysis of pornography and
history has been that the more there is
a taboo of any kind in a culture the
more you will get imaginations that
profane that that sacred subject
whatever it is so I have the feeling
that possibly the majority of these
horrific fantasies of child abuse and
murder and so on may be coming from
other forces in the culture not because
people really want to enact such such
frightful scenarios so and I again I as
a student of psychopathology
I am simply doubtful of a direct
correlation between people who indulge
in such fantasies and the people who
actually carry them out because we have
the example of jeweled array and the
countess Dracula in Nero these such
examples they did not need French in
Agra or Internet in order to stimulate
their act we don't know those two no we
don't that's right remember there's two
young boys in England who killed the
toddler turns out that their father was
an addict of snuff films and one of them
was a precise way in which they killed
that kid and there's some boys who've
just strangled friends from the rear
seat of a car they strangled sitting in
the front seat they got that from
Godfather two they said but it may be
that the milk that there are millions
and millions of people may see similar
scenes only a small number may may be
made me pushed into committing such acts
but perhaps they would have done these
things anyway are we going to close down
the whole society and you know in order
to prevent such a sociopath from acting
who might have act in any way John what
you have written about the role of shame
to get changed on it is that what you
want to do when you say you want to
change the culture that's why I think
the campaign against Time Warner is so
interesting that what what it is it's a
clear appealed to shame and I think it's
working the noises I hear within the
Time Warner Empire or or shame noises
they can't we can't make them do
anything it's a tiny part of their
empire they're a tiny part of the
cultural pollution business but there
writhing there
stunned by this they don't know what to
do it's it's the purest leverage that
shame induction has had in years
and I think it's a good lesson yeah but
but what is the bottom line let us say
that your campaign and it's a larger
campaign now to sort of shame Time
Warner which is one of the big guys on
the block to get rid of that sort of
gangster rap music and what else picks
it up someone else picks it up let's say
another big company
bertelsmann I guess Sony whatever and
they can be shamed into it or shamed out
of it but then you go down the food
chain through smaller companies or if
you can shame the smaller companies that
I mean that's hard because they don't
have theme parks they don't have books
they don't have a lot of other things
you can boycott but suppose you can then
you're gonna get Nuka brand new
companies putting out gangsta rap I
don't see this jammed same campaign
going a company the company garage door
garage I think we're trying to get a
psychic movement going among the people
and so that it really is a demand-side
revolution you're gonna have to tell
people that we were all ashamed of this
stuff and let's not buy it so you're not
gonna go company by company it's not a
supply end thing we're just trying to
get the whole mechanism going in the
culture well what you have to do is
rebuild authority in the family because
the people are buying this gangster-rap
are predominantly white suburban addled
adolescents whose parents are letting
them do it the other thing that's
happening is this is creating a great
new debate within the black community I
think black people are very conflicted
about this they don't like to see their
culture attacked by whites on the other
hand a lot of a lot of them are very
very nervous about the image of black
people that's being put out in these
songs so I think this campaign and to
the great credit of dr. Tucker has given
great leverage to people in the in the
black community who want change I
believe that there should be public
incentives for the great producers and
they and the end time water and so on to
start focusing on quality productions
and I don't mean Shirley Temple
Productions but I think when when the
momentum of the culture is to is to
Japan aesthetics in the style again of
the old Hollywood studio system where we
look back at some of those movies
extraordinary quality at every level
from the lighting to the male
to narrative to plot and so on and and
and you could sit with with grandparents
and children the same room and not be
embarrassed that you could have a
multi-generational experience in pass
through the legendary Hays office that
was censorship well well you see this
these arguments are actually were going
on in early Hollywood there were
producers who wanted to make movies more
upscale to make them to bring culture to
the masses others who wanted to bring
blood and guts after all let's remember
the great the great circulation Wars of
the William Randolph Hearst era it
appears to be the case that the working
working-class audiences the popular
audience really does like kind of a high
level of sex and violence that may make
opera middle class white people
uncomfortable so I worry about a kind of
elitist attitude that perhaps has crept
into somewhat some of this cultural that
it's a class attitude but there are
differences among people and there's
some people be better off if some of
that material was kept out of their
hands and it was as Ben says censorship
agreed to by the industry through the
Hays office and the best movies that was
the golden era of Hollywood the thirty
yes as it happens this is true after I
hate to say because I do love lurid
pornography but after the Hays rules
went through we had spent fantastic
films of the 30s and 40s that are still
studied in classrooms
Bobby you had alluded to it family
values religious values are we in for
what would be what the fourth Great
Awakening a turn of the cultural
pendulum well some people see for a for
example this Promise Keepers movement
which is men getting together fifty
thousand seventy five thousand in an
auditorium where they pay money and they
come and they pray and they sing hymns
and they promise fidelity to their wives
and so forth some see that is the
beginning of a religious awakening but I
really think the public culture could
only be reformed by a religious
awakening in the Regency in England
beginning of the last century it was a
dissolute corrupt culture and it was
followed by the Victorian era and the
difference apparently was Methodism
percolating through the upper classes
and upper-middle classes and then to the
working classes so without a religious
revival I'm not sure where we're going
I have to say that I'd agree with what
you said Josh Brooke I I speak as a as a
radical 60s libertarian I think in fact
that there is a movement back toward
religious fundamentalism in the world
because of the failure of modernism
modernism which gave only nihilism and
has destroyed the education I think of
for the masses i I've been warning my
fellow liberals for a long time that
there they are there they have pushed
the country to the right and that and
that I see among many young people a
return to traditional religion as a kind
of a hunger for spirituality that is
missing - I think just to pick up a
thought about liberalism that liberalism
has never really been endorsed by any
major religion everybody feels a little
uncomfortable about the emptiness of it
and III think there's the beginning of a
turn toward a religious but but I don't
I don't see any religion filling that
need you get books like Gertrude
Himmelfarb calling for a return to
Victorian values well who's going to do
that normally a church does something
like that but no church now has that
status quite that's crass but the
American imagination one final little
conversation here is does this belong in
politics are these political issues Bob
Dole was criticized in part for saying
oh he's never really paid much attention
to this and now he's making a big
political issue out of it
President Clinton is apparently telling
some of his staff a how come he's
getting all the publicity I mentioned it
first
should this be part of this political
thing certainly it should a political
leader is not just a somebody who talks
about economics he's also a cultural
force and there's no reason why that
cultural force shouldn't be exerted in
good directions well I I feel look at
the Kennedys I mean mrs. mrs. Kennedy
brought a distinction and a kind of
feeling for high-art to the White House
that I think we sorely need I think
politicians should speak out I just
don't want Washington to do anything
about it
I think they'll only screw it up I think
it's it's it belongs to the people that
we're trying to grapple with a highly
democratic wild and raucous public
culture and we have to grapple with it
ourselves nobody's going to impose an
answer to this and Bob Dole and the
president
Linton they're not gonna solve our
problems I'm glad they're talking about
it you'll Riley too but I don't want
them to solve it for it's that on this
wild and raucous culture there is also
some very vibrant health I mean I think
so does anybody yes yes I love America I
think I think America the healthiest
place in the world yeah you you are
slouching toward Gomorrah well I think
but I think that's true of Western
civilization generally industrialized
countries of Western Europe are sort of
heading in the same direction we are and
the poor Arab world the Muslim world are
trying to keep it out you know they got
the Iranian police running around
looking for a satellite dishes so they
can't get American culture it's
ridiculous it's dictatorial but one does
see that they have a certain kind of
point you're anti censorship in Iran but
in favor of no John I think the good
part about this cultural moment is that
everything is on the table everyone has
a voice everyone's a publisher
everyone's a consumer there's no
suppress minority everybody can say
whatever they want and you're getting a
lot of pain now but I think something
good could come out of it okay thank you
Camille Talia Robert Bork and John Leo
and thank you please send your comments
and questions to New River media one
one-five-zero 17th Street Northwest
Washington DC to zero zero three six or
we can be reached by email at think TV
at aol.com for think-tank
I'm Ben wattenberg
[Music]
this has been a production of BJ W
incorporated in association with New
River media which are solely responsible
for its content